I haven't started doing the coffee animals yet. Would that be a good next step?
Yes. So a lot of people are afraid to do coffee animals because it's going to be messy. I'm afraid to
do it because I don't have enough time. Remember, on the member site, there's the easy peasy way to do coffee
animals. I also have it on the seven phases of detoxification site. You know, I'll have access to that
easy peasy way to do coffee animals where you can stand to do it in the shower. Makes it really easy.
That's how I always did a coffee animal. I didn't lay on one side of the other. Well, I just never did
that. So they worked for me. They helped me a lot when I was doing them. I don't do coffee animals now.
I haven't done them for a while. But coffee animals have multiple benefits. Not just
that people think coffee animals are for, well, I have constipation, so I do coffee animals. No.
Coffee animals are to stimulate your parasympathetics, which are to stimulate your liver detoxification pathways
to stimulate your immune system function to in parasympathetic stimulation, calms your nervous system,
calms your anxiety. It has so many benefits. And I always suggest people go on
our website and look up sympathetic parasympathetic. And I have a video that explains the parasympathetic
nervous system and I have some downloadable PDFs on other ways to stimulate your parasympathetics
and other ways to calm your sympathetic. But that's the reason why you do coffee animals. So yes,
we coffee animals are a good next step. Don't shy away from those or be afraid of them.